merci monsieur le président voilà 21
jours que le liban connaît une situation
de crise
situation qui a été déclenchée par le
souhait du gouvernement de taxer les
appels numérique de type web sap 7 ce
projet de taxe à est une goutte d'eau en
fait qui a fait déborder un vase déjà
bien plein bien plein à savoir une
corruption importante
une situation économique dégradée des
investissements qui s'échappe des
services publics qui sont défaillants
pas d'accès à l'eau courante ni à
l'électricité
par ailleurs ce pays est fortement
fragilisé par la guerre en syrie lundi
l'agencé moody's a dégradé pour la
deuxième fois de l'année la note du pays
qui désormais fait l'objet est qualifiée
de pays spéculatifs
le 29 octobre dernier interrogé à
l'assemblée nationale le ministre des
affaires étrangères a déclaré que la
démission du premier ministre ne fait
qu'aggraver la crise il a par ailleurs
présenté les deux convictions du
gouvernement à savoir appeler les
responsables libanais à garantir la
stabilité des institutions et écouter la
population
cette déclaration a été mal interprétée
par la population locale qui dénonce
dans la rue l'ingérence des politiques d
payer des pays étrangers dans la
politique nationale du pays dans une
lettre ouverte
un plaidoyer citoyens appellent les
nations unies et la communauté
européenne à répondre et à écouter les
véritables attentes des citoyens à
savoir une véritable indépendance du
liban et l'établissement d'un état laïc
la france est depuis longtemps un ami un
pays ami du liban
donc ma question est simple comment
content comptez vous répondre aux
attentes du peuple libanais à savoir un
système politique moins corrompus et une
amélioration de la situation économique